[Music]
sex news what churches love sex oh I got
so many stories about Church sexy not
not not my sexing but somebody else sex
sex inside the church story I knew that
people went to church just to go get
godly women because they are the most
tempted uh-huh and horny have you ever
seen a bit of a penis
there's something about Church that
makes people horny like crazy it's
because bidding they repress their
sexuality and some of them too by the
way
be a Clairol holy but that's the guys
because they just want to eat you know
when I was in second grade I was
Christian school and when I first got
there I just came from a public school
it was popular for the second graders to
all make out did you make out with her
yet did you make out what did you hear
Billy made out what this person everyone
was just making out that's how you get
mono kids
everyone's like six or seven years old
that's crazy submit it by Bart's third
finger yeah oh ah the penis isn't that
that xi xi finger I think I three thumbs
up maybe I don't know I don't know where
I came from I'm just playing along a
family ran swingers club was
masquerading as a church why was I not
invited
so hating on this [ __ ] I remember they
told me it they sent you right well I
didn't check my email I was in Hawaii
you know they call the most of them for
this story cuz I'm a journalism so tell
me to do dad Tiffany
yes this club the consul's the social
club in Nashville Tennessee thank you
[ __ ] [ __ ] horny ass Nash's there's a
home of country music music and [ __ ]
country music music music not just the
regular country music but the country
music music you know what I mean home
now no there when you masquerade as a
church and you [ __ ] lotta people
their third or their parent there there
you go music music so apparently they
had a club already like a swingers club
established but then they announced that
they had plans to move to a suburb and
open up like an office there or like
another club there's an office smells
like bleach all the time so then
neighbors found out of this suburb that
this club was planning on going into
their suburb so then they were outraged
and they quickly passed laws directly
aimed at preventing the sex club from
opening their no sex club in my town
yeah so then the owners announced that
instead they would be opening a church
that it's open to members only but they
promised that there would be no sex
there and unlike the they would just
have you know specific rooms for church
events like the choir room makes sense
yeah like the ladies sing yeah so then
these two undercover investigators they
went into the club and then they
discovered that there was just a whole
lot of [ __ ] everywhere where should I
should have been a church and the
investigator had to get evidence in day
at the login about two thousand meetings
and attended about three thousand events
and participated because they didn't
want to be ousted as investigators yeah
John why is this investigation going on
for six years it's like one of those
situations why are you always falling
asleep when you're giving these reports
smoking a cigarette right if you come
out of that house is a little bit
suspicious hmm
apparently after that they that night
that they went there was like this four
page report that they created where they
described all these things that they
witness which was like they saw his
pregnant lady getting her nipple sucked
by two different men they there was this
other one where there was this couple
having sex and one of the investigators
asked like oh can you take a picture of
us and so like he took a picture of him
while they were having sex it's not
shocking
yeah and there was just a whole bunch of
other rooms and like that choir room was
really a dungeon room where they would
have like BDSM ball gags that's pretty
dope Shh
was it really like the shape of a church
or was it like a warehouse or like I'd
like to see the room so it was called
United fellowship center which was owned
by freedom for all eat which is the
lease holder looks like askew
yeah and then that's the building damn
they make him Bank if they go for that
whole building mm-hmm yeah they're they
charge $40 for couples $20 for single
women and I believe $50 for single men
that's not cheap a month to enter these
party Oh
so each time are you going how you hear
about these parties just one month they
have a website I don't know because
every time I think of like orgy I'm
thinking like all paid beautiful actors
in like the porn world in the real world
it's people of walmart that's [ __ ]
each other that's true it is a form of
prostitution because there's exchange of
money so not parently it is legal I
don't think it's prostitution because
you're not paying for sex you're just
paying for the entry oh it's your
[ __ ] whatever the [ __ ] you want yeah
it's kind of like I'm just paying for
the gym membership but it's up to me if
I want to work out yup yeah so this
man famous al Wow whoa whoa he's a
participant
he runs the club with his family so
really this forms our bid him in his
biceps
that means jacks off a lot yeah
apparently like his this family here is
just heavily involved in the swingers
world and he runs this club with his
niece who's pictured here she yeah so
this is his sisters or their [ __ ] for
sure well what they claim so this is a
still of like an interview when they
were at this swingers convention and
they were like probably sitting like
yeah it's a family-run business like
everyone in our family is like somehow
involved in that we love it it's awesome
and then she's like yeah we've been to
the cruises we've been to other events
like in Vegas and things like that and
then so the interviewer was like so do
you guys might participate with each
other like in the same room or do you
like accidentally walk into each other
and they were like no we're really we
stay on the opposite end of wherever we
are so we don't like bump into each
other so they don't like try to involve
in like incest or anything that's
respectable when they were talking about
going on the cruises they're like yeah
she stays on her side of the ship I'll
stay on my skin of the ship and then the
guys like it's not weird at all that
this is your uncle and then the
interviewer rostral s like wait so how
like when did you find out that your
family was involved in this she was like
I had always known my family was
involved and being swingers like it's
just a norm for me she's like I can't
even remember how old I was when I
discovered it yes but I grew up in the
family you really liked her friends too
growing up they own you oh my
interesting it's the same thing as like
a Chinese restaurant like why is that
weird to open a Chinese restaurant uncle
it's not you know like you guys it's
just a family business like any other
family business so then now this city
that they're in I have so many questions
for them I know I me too
can you imagine the type of complaints
they receive or should that the disgust
it's so different than a restaurant
because it's like oh we need to order
more produce
ran out too soon they may not even get
complaints cuz everyone's having an
orgasm yep please clean up after your
come come on all over the ceiling I
wonder what their Yelp reviews are like
excellent five stars I [ __ ] came so
many times party was awesome now the
city is suing the honors because don't
be [ __ ] over here that's what they're
saying no so what they're the business
that they're operating completely
violates the property owners permit
which is to operate as a church so
that's why they're being sued that's
their religion the religion of [ __ ]
then you gots to get it verified well
that's why it's a violation of the new
law that they prove the implemented to
prevent the sex did they have to go into
this like town to do this [ __ ] there's
so many like cheap vacant land all over
you know where's that Kentucky Tennessee
yeah I know you can buy homes out there
for like 50 grand or whatever so they
can build their own little facility in
the middle of nowhere and have a party
party [ __ ] town in an unincorporated
little place yeah so another thing is
that this church was within a thousand
feet of a school which also violates I
see yeah that's not cool cuz you don't
want kids walking home from school and
they see like a guy getting spanked with
a whip from another guy and he has a
ball gag on and a girl's behind a dude
with a strap-on dildo I mean that booty
yeah and then there's another lady over
there that's got you know clothespins on
her nipples well they wouldn't see any
of that I mean like you're gonna be
hearing just screams all the time you
just don't know if they forgot to leave
the blinds closed
yeah I'm just so curious like what
everything would smell look sound
you probably have a really good like
custodial service you should go to a sex
party and see what it's like clean it
all up
I'd be down just to like watch though
I'd just be like check it out I'm like I
think you'll be able to just watch
you're gonna get through horny no I'm
just thinking like oh like block out
Toby's but they would feel uncomfortable
with you just watching Oh some people
are like the boyars some people are the
participators you know saying just going
with nose plugs
you might smell good in there yeah I
might sometimes I enjoy the smell of sex
if it's your sex or you do that do you
enjoy the smell of it I smell another
man's nut juice I won't get a boner no I
mean like I'm just imagining that it
smells like locker room oh yeah so if it
smells like a gym locker room I don't
know if no matter how hot a grow is I
don't know if it did I don't think I
couldn't perform hello my mother Joe
Malians please like the video and for
more beautiful videos look up there
[Music]